in his meeting with the emir of qatar
u.s president joe biden began by talking
about russia and then the united arab
emirates a sign of his country's concern
i also want to note that the uae
defeated a ballistic missile attack
launched by the houthis
separate issue from
yemen yesterday
and we've been in daily contact with the
uae to address
those threats the timing of the launch
was important it came as the israeli
president was visiting another step
toward normalizing relations between the
countries the missile fragments came
down in a remote area the uae responded
to the missile with a strike of its own
reportedly on a houthi missile launch
site in yemen across the u.s government
the houthis actions are being condemned
this is a challenge that we are very
focused on we're very focused on it in
terms of
providing
support that our partners saudi arabia
and the uae need to defend themselves
against these types of terrorist attacks
the president said he has directed the
secretary of defense to work to shore up
uae's defenses clearly
these attacks have have uh
um have not been 100 successful we
continue to
as i said to fadi explore opportunities
to improve our our defenses and
and the defenses of our emirati partners
as well
the biden administration came into
office promising to focus on ending the
very long war in yemen but recent
strikes and statements make it clear
that is still far from happening now
patti kolhain al jazeera washington